dal pesce al filosofo questo è un
bellissimo libro di homer smith
pubblicato a boston
nei primi anni 50 come smith è stato un
grande fisiologo la maggior parte delle
cose che noi pensiamo di scoprire il
laboratorio si trova nei suoi libri uno
più bello dell'altro
in questo c'è scritto che ciascuno di
noi non è quello che mangia ma è quello
che il suo rene è capace di conservare
ma cosa servono i reni a produrre urina
direte voi
giusto ma il rene a tante altre funzioni
ancora e per il rene che noi viviamo qui
a dispetto dell'ambiente a noi sembra
normale di vivere sulla terra ma la
terra è ostile alla vita almeno lo era
ma per certi versi lo è ancora noi siamo
fatti per due terzi di acqua e le nostre
cellule sono immerse in un fluido che ha
e deve avere una composizione ben
precisa ecco la funzione principale del
rene proprio questa di mantenere la
composizione del fluido che bagna le
cellule precise basta un poco più di
sodio e ne ha più un po meno perché il
cervello ne soffra il potassio
se portasse aumenta si ferma al cuore
non preoccupatevi c'è il vostro rene e
voi non lo sapete neppure il rene che ci
dà la capacità di accedere il rennes e
poi sa straordinariamente
eliminare tutto quello che in eccesso
noi possiamo prendere quanto c'è nel
successo acqua e sale per esempio il
rene elimina ciò che non serve
e lo fa minuto per minuto con una
precisione che nessuna bilancia di
nessun farmacista sarebbe in grado di
fare il rennes e quindi che ci permette
di riuscire a superare avere il
superfluo ma serene smette di funzionare
improvvisamente noi moriamo nel giro di
pochi giorni
e perché le sostanze di scarto che noi
ogni giorno produciamo sono tossiche
rene si adatta anche molto bene al danno
possiamo anche avere una riduzione della
funzione del rene fino a 80 85 per cento
e stare ancora abbastanza bene e dopo
c'è la dialisi ma la dialisi non
sostituisce tutte le funzioni del rene
non quella per esempio di contribuire a
produrre globuli rossi attraverso
l'eritropoietina né quella di proteggere
le ossa con la vitamina d
senza i reni saremo un po rachitici
quante persone vivono con la dialisi
circa due milioni di persone al mondo e
per loro
spendiamo più di mille miliardi di
dollari la cifra pazzesca enorme le
persone in dialisi sono soprattutto
negli stati uniti in europa in giappone
in australia il 90 per cento dei
dializzati e lì ma negli altri nel altra
parte nel mondo nei paesi emergenti
la dialisi e poca o nulla ma lì vivono
cinque miliardi di persone per un certo
verso la dialisi per i paesi ricchi e
fare in modo che questo non sia più così
e stata una grande sfida per tutto il
mondo e per tutti noi
ed è stato questo l'impegno di tanti
anni di ricerca ma come si arriva alla
dialisi
vi racconto una storia mario ha 50 anni
è sempre stato bene a un certo punto fa
la visita di leva quando era giovane li
trovano del sangue nelle urine ma
nessuno ci fa caso andando avanti negli
anni sta sempre bene fino a che è un
certo punto un bel giorno comincia a
orinare tanto anche di notte ea forti
mal di testa non ne può più
va in farmacia per prenderne un
analgesico il farmacista riprova la
pressione a 200 su 110
ma com'è possibile fa lui ho sempre
avuto la pressione è normale
il farmacista lo invita andare a pronto
soccorso dal pronto soccorso gli fanno
una serie di esami a un'insufficienza
renale grave dicono i medici e dopo due
settimane va in dialisi quattro ore al
giorno tre giorni su sette per tutte le
settimane del mese per tutti
i mesi dell'anno e sarà così fino a
quando non ci sarà un per lui un
trapianto un trapianto di rene questa è
una storia un po come un'altra di
ipertensione di diabete che alla lunga
danneggia nel rene e quindi ci sono ci
ha pensato quante persone possono avere
una storia analoga ben sappiamo che il
10 per cento della popolazione mondiale
a qualche forma di danno renale che se
trascurata progredirà nel tempo ed è
quindi molto importante pensare a questo
di solito sono persone che hanno
proteine nelle urine soprattutto
albumina e noi sappiamo dai nostri studi
che l'albumina anche se poco presente
nelle urine primo ta poi darà un danno
al cuoa arene e poi anche al cuore per
fortuna il rene però si può proteggere
una bellissima notizia che voglio
condividere con voi
ed è un cambiamento rispetto a prima
si pensava che ci fosse solo la dialisi
invece c'è la possibilità di proteggere
rene come con farmaci che abbassano la
pressione e che fanno parte della
categoria degli inibitori dell'enzima di
conversione per l'angiotensina parolone
molto difficile sono farmaci che vengono
utilizzati normalmente come si dice in
gergo antipertensivi e proteggono il
rennes e dal deterioramento e la
funzione ma proteggono lui alla lunga
anche il cuore dall'infarto dello
scompenso è partita proprio da qui da
bergamo
questa ricerca che ha visto un grande
sforzo collaborativo tra ricercatori
clinici dell'istituto mario e del
nostro ospedale e da adesso questa
terapia è usata in tutto il mondo anche
negli stati uniti che di solito vengono
prima di noi
come abbiamo fatto
come abbiamo fatto a scoprire questa
terapia che protegge il rene con l'aiuto
degli animali senza topi ratti
non c'è progresso si ferma la medicina
bisogna che ne siamo consapevoli che
ognuno di noi lo sappia
grazie a questi piccoli roditori abbiamo
capito il rapporto che esiste tra la
perdita della normale funzione del rene
il passaggio di albumina più tossico e
la presenza di infiammazione che il
primo stadio della malattia renale dal
topo l'uomo poi il passaggio è stato
breve quei farmaci che erano efficaci
nell'animale sono stati efficacissimi
nell'uomo
se un paziente non viene trattato la
riga rossa la sua funzione renale si
deteriora nel tempo si riduce fino al
punto che ha bisogno di dialisi e
trapianto con i farmaci che abbiamo
studiato e che abbiamo scoperto non ha
la funzione renale viene mantenuta non
sia una riduzione la funzione renale
almeno per i primi tre anni e cosa non
ci aspettavamo la funzione nerale
addirittura migliora dopo tre anni
perché questo perché è una questione di
cellule staminali con questi farmaci non
riusciamo a mantenere il patrimonio di
cellule staminali che ciascuno di noi ha
nel proprio rene ce ne sono dappertutto
e l'abbiamo in tutti gli organi li
abbiamo trovati in tanti distretti a
bergamo abbiamo visti nel rene li
abbiamo studiati negli animali il
abbiamo trovati lire piano trovati anche
nell'uomo le abbiamo isolato come si
dice in gergo le abbiamo caratterizzate
abbiamo visto che cosa producevano
abbiamo visto quali loro potenziale con
i farmaci progetto tegano il rene
abbiamo mantenuto l'integrita di tutte
queste cellule staminali
il risultato
forse dato che si è fermata la
progressione malattia renale
il rene giorno dopo giorno si è riparato
e così la funzione renale è migliorata
certo per curare la malattia renale per
fermare la progressione malattia renale
bisogna partire presto dopo è troppo
tardi
e come si fa basta un semplice esame
delle urine
basta vedere se abbiamo proteine
soprattutto albumina nelle urine
se l'abbiamo questo segnale bisogna
intervenire ma quasi nessuno lo fa al
rumeno aurine non ci si pensa
c'è poca sensibilità per le malattie
renali
se voi pensate il rennes e negletto
anche nel linguaggio popolare si dice
cuor di leone o uno che ha fegato ma non
c'è niente di simile per il rene e nella
bibbia per un'infinità di volte si parla
di sangue e di cuore ma di rene una sola
volta quando dio per giudicare gli
uomini guarda i loro reni perché i reni
erano considerate la sede del
temperamento delle emozioni e anche
delle virtù e poi via via nessuno più
parla di rene nella letteratura fino a
shakespeare fine del 1500 le allegre
comari di windsor terzo atto falso
rivolgendosi parla di reni rivolgendosi
a colui il quale pensa che sia un
gentiluomo che masse bruchi dice il dtc
la sua disavventura fa stasera nascosto
in una cesta di panni sporchi che è
stata buttata nel tamigi e rivolgendosi
a gentiluomo dice man of my kids nice
letteralmente o uomo dei miei reni cioè
una persona come me col mio temperamento
e forse anche per la mia corporatura
se non fosse per il rennes a rené
saremmo ancora negli stagni e saremmo
pesci ora noti il rene che ci ha
permesso di evolvere e ha permesso a
certi animali di lasciare gli oceani
fiumi per vivere sulla terra senza reni
qui sulla terra non ci sarebbero i
filosofi grazie per la vostra attenzione